you know it's really hard it varies from
individual to individual so much if I
don't eat protein with a meal personally
I start to get hungry but if I don't eat
carbs I get a headache so I have to eat
certain amount of carbs in my diet some
people can go on an Atkins diet pure
protein and be fine and that's just not
comfortable for me I find I fill up very
quickly with a little bit of fats other
people you know eat fats they're not
full and they've taken a lot more
calories because of that research seems
to show that a high protein diet is very
effective for weight loss a pure protein
diet is almost impossible to maintain
and not healthy in the long run so sort
of Atkins diet and a low glycemic index
has been shown to work that means
carbohydrates that are metabolized more
slowly than processed foods like white
bread and rice not so good pastas etc
but steel cut oats sweet potatoes
instead of regular potatoes these are
low glycemic index foods that don't get
broken down in your system that quickly
those helped I mentioned already
proteins help low the right fats in the
right amounts is important because you
need fats in your diet so olive oil
Omega threes nut oils and things like
that
I've been shown to be somewhat helpful
and then you have to mix that up in
proper proportions and that again is
gonna vary from individual to individual
but I think a diet that includes a
significant proportion of calories from
protein low glycemic index carbohydrates
and proper fats is the right one to do
then the question is for weight loss
what's a good diet and I think that
cutting that calories is critical that
it's really the only way to have
significant weight loss
everybody's metabolic rates a little
different but most people don't live on
much less than 2,000 calories a day for
normal and therefore we have to cut back
by 500 or 800 calories a day in order to
get a good weight loss a pound of fat a
pound of anything in your body is 3500
calories so roughly a pound of fat 3500
calories 500 calories a day for seven
days
should be a pound so if you cut back 500
calories a day and it's simple
one less Snapple one less bag of chips
add the two together that's about 500
calories if you do that every day for a
week you should lose a pound now you
can't keep doing that forever because
your body's metabolism is gonna slow
down and you're not gonna continue to
lose a pound a day the amount of
calories that women need versus that men
need does differ for a man the same
height and weight as a woman it might
differ probably not dramatically as you
would think it has something to do with
muscle mass men tend to have a little
bit more muscle mass but again it's
individual so a woman with the same
height and weight in the same muscle
mass as a man probably not dramatically
different but most women are a little
smaller height why is a little less
muscle mass per that same weight and
therefore their metabolic rate tends to
be a little lower they need a little bit
fewer calories so might be 2500 calories
for a man in 2,000 calories for a woman
it's a very individual it's a whole
nother area really adolescence and it's
not my specialty but adolescence really
it's the same equation I think it the
important thing about adolescents and
kids is they're at a time when they're
still developing their behaviors it's
much easier to change behaviors so that
you can encourage more activity get that
involved in their life you can encourage
the healthy eating habits volume control
on the other hand it's very very
difficult when a child is hungry to hold
that food from them so giving them the
right foods is really important and I
don't think actually eliminating certain
foods that are the wrong foods is the
answer either because you can get that
counterintuitive response of it's held
back for me for so long I just want more
of it and so there has to be that proper
balance and it depends on the child's
personality and the parents parenting
style it's really hard but again cutting
back calories a little bit has been
shown to be the most effective way to do
this on the other hand in kids that are
growing cutting back
too much can actually impair ultimately
growth and it's been shown that cutting
back calories actually shortens
children's ultimate height now I think
it's a much better to be an inch shorter
than 50 pounds heavier and it's a
worthwhile trade-off as long as it's
done carefully